people of the internet retrorec contour
here welcome back to harry potter and
the chamber
of secrets it is evening here in the
gryffindor common room
we did just lose to slytherin in our
last video
i apologize you guys i apologize uh i am
not good at quidditch that was a tough
match though really tough match against
slytherin
so we're gonna head down looks like ron
is waiting for us
and let's see what the evenings
and then i had to go to sleep i think
we're getting close to the end told me
that ginny's gone missing
they can't find her anywhere we go but
it gets worse
it's hermione she was attacked she's
been petrified okay
i found her just like nearly headless
nick outside moaning myrtles stiffers
aboard
mcgonagall told me that they were doing
everything they could to find ginny
so i went to see hermione i found a
piece of paper in her hand
a pace tour from an old live people
that must have been what she was doing
before she was doing the music so loud
was the page about
it was all about basilisks the giant
snakes
oh the basilisk apparently a bacillus
can kill people by just staring at them
anything else yeah spiders don't like
them
they run away when they're back yeah the
story they really
move stuff around written the word pipes
on the page
pipes pipes that's all just tied just
places
this is it this is the answer the
monster in the chamber of secrets is a
basilisk
a giant snake that's why i've been
hearing the voice and nobody else's home
boom
there you go harry parcell harry do you
think ginny might be in the chamber of
secrets along with that flipping big
snake
maybe mcgonagall said they searched baby
we're in the castle but no one knows
where the chamber is
we've got to find her okay so what we
need to know is how the battle is been
getting around the place
a giant snake surely someone would have
seen it pipes
pipes wrong it's been using the plumbing
i've been hearing the voice inside the
wall they're getting there they're
getting there number of secrets
what if it's a bathroom what have you
seen moaning myrtle's bathroom
dun dun dun dun dun dun the place is
crawling with prefects looking for ginny
i'll go first myrtles on the second
floor
moaning myrtle second floor harry's like
i'll go first wait what's the remembral
out for
rescue jimmy oh this is it this is it so
here we go guys
i i didn't realize we were this
close to the end game i thought we were
getting pretty close okay so
we're doing it right now rescue jenny
find the entrance to the chamber of
secrets in the girls bathroom
on floor two okay so we already know
where that is uh we we did get all the
notice board items last time so i think
we're ready to do this man
uh let's see actually before we go to
end game
i want to take a look at oh man so we're
still
missing oh my goodness we're still
missing
so many wizard cards
you know what how many uh beans do i
have right now though not very mini do i
oh my goodness a i think it's enough to
buy
one if fred and george are in their room
tonight
maybe they're not in there with the fact
that jenny is uh
been taken you think they're still
hanging out here
oh i should have just ran like i always
do
let's go this way flippity jibbing
flippity jibbet
okay they are still here and i only have
one more wizard card to buy in here
perfect albert grunion the inventor of
the dun bomb
how much is it 40 right 30 30 30.
perfect i'll take it we'll take the last
please ah albert grunion
where would we be without his
outstanding contribution to explosive
tongue
[Music]
all right let's take a look number 97
albert grunion
oh my goodness dude late 1800s
wow so he's born in 1803 but lived to
inventor of the dung bomb so there you
go if you were wondering will dung bombs
be
in hogwarts legacy they uh
will definitely have been invented
voluminous balloons are a great one
dude that was actually really good that
i went there because
i just upgraded my health too by getting
uh
i think it's what 10 beans or beans 10
wizard cards and then it upgrades
so that was a good call to do that
before we go down into the chamber and
try and rescue jenny here
all right so where is this dude he's
over there and we're gone we're out of
here
to the chamber
oh this way trust me i know where i'm
going i know where i'm going guys
all right so on floor two but they said
there's going to be more prefects out
so let's see if we actually see some as
we're
and nothing so far yeah i didn't think
they were like out here
it's probably once i actually get on to
the second floor right
actually no way because the girls
bathroom's like right there dude
yeah there's no prefix there's no
prefects around what are you talking
about ron
oh it's you harry potter there's ron
he just appears how you died oh
it was dreadful it happened right
here i didn't because olive hornby was
teasing me about my glasses
i was crying when i heard someone come
in
it was a boy and he began speaking a
different language
i went to tell him to go to use his own
bathroom
and then i died
where exactly did you see the eyes
over there
harry say something something in parcel
tongue what's gone harry
open sesame open up
english
come on ron why can't you do it
you should be able to do it ron just
from hearing him one time right
i must be miles under the school
deathly hallows joke hopefully uh
no spoilers for any of you oh goodness
all right so i guess ron doesn't come
along with me
weird but okay should we save i guess we
should probably say right
okay wow this actually looks really cool
down here
they did a good job with this i can't
remember what this fight is like at all
though
i do not remember what it's like at all
she is tom tom
riddle she's still alive but only just
only we've got to get her out of here
there's a battle
oh harry come on tom won't come until
it's called
let me tell you about the real reason
jenny's like this she's been writing in
the diary
my she just blinked for months i think
until i had enough power to start
pouring a little of my soul back into
her
what do you mean that's so fast easily
the magic behind that absorb threatening
messages on the walls and set the
serpent of slytherin on the mudbloods
and nearly had this nick
no i'm afraid so ginny told me all about
you harry
so i decided to show you my famous catch
of that great oath hagrid to gain your
trust you framed hagrid
yes but you harry potter how is it that
you
managed to defeat the greatest wizard of
all time what do you
care haven't you realized yet
i am lord voldemort the greatest
i'm going to teach you a little comment
where are you at let's match the powers
of lord voldemort
heir of salazar slytherin against the
famous
harry potter kill him i hate snakes and
games man
i hate it i hate snaking video games
seriously dude the snake insecuro
this thing actually looks really
freaking vicious
oh my goodness oh wait wait what do i do
what do i do okay
okay it's uh looks like it's put on x
did that hurt him oh it did let's go
dude let's go
drop the sword though oh my gosh that's
way too close
ah he's huge
but anyway what i was saying about the
uh the diary
i've been watching some videos like
dedicated to explaining that like what
would have happened you know
if voldemort or i should say tom riddle
diary tom riddle had been able to uh
like finish what he was trying to do
with jenny it's such a unique horcrux
right
it's like would it have created a copy
of him or would it have somehow
merged with the original voldemort
i don't know it's it's pretty
interesting though
do i have to wait for that little like
shiny
or can i just do it like now
oh i guess not fox is still up there
hanging out okay
all right let's see am i doing something
wrong here or maybe you just have to
like survive him a couple of times
right in the middle again
all right dodge it wait for it wait for
it come on do it do it do it
oh we went with two that time
oh three how about now oh there he goes
okay we heard him a little bit more
right there
oh gosh he's gonna come right for me
isn't he
no okay he's going that way can i jump
up here gotta take the stairs
all right come on harry get the sword
okay not over there dying harry i heard
him
i heard him oh he was over there
what is this oh a cauldron cake i
probably should have saved it
if i got hit again
man you can tell they really tried to
not make it too scary for kids
because he doesn't even like does he
even try to bite you like i'm kind of
tempted to
oh no oh no i gotta get closer there we
go
oh it's not hitting him i'm kind of
tempted to get closer to him to see if
he even tries to
to eat you right
they're like what can what kind of
attack can we give the basketless
basilisk that won't be too scary for
kids nothing you couldn't do maybe we
could just have him like blast
acid out of his mouth okay that'll work
all right come on show me your weak spot
where is it i love how you can't even
cast like any spells at all they just
take away
your wand
there we go that hurt him a little bit
oh my keeps knocking the sword out of my
hands though
yeah this this boss fight's not bad like
i feel like they could have handled it
much better
obviously but it's not terrible
i just wish i mean they kind of
made up some power for the sword right
instead of being able to uh
actually run up and hit the basilisk try
to stab him
i don't know if he has another phase or
anything but i gotta say it's so far it
is much easier than the
voldemort fight from uh the pc game of
sorcerer's stone
much easier
nice i think one more hit might do it i
see right now should let you run up and
see this okay it does hurt if you run
into him i was curious like
do you even take damage at all yeah i
want those birdie bobby thank you
i don't think he would ever actually
bite you though
any of you in the chat know for sure let
me know in the comments
will the snake even attempt i don't want
to find out
kill him i'm too afraid if oh we put his
eyes out or did fox just get his
because eyes said you can still smell
him oh yeah he's not even
he's not even looking at me anymore
oh he's so confused
oh that was close though
another let's see i'm just gonna get him
why is it not hitting him
there we go come on run up there harry
run up there and stab him oh there it is
dude there it is
oh harry doesn't even grab it
and stab the book
and there he goes one horcrux down guys
you gotta wait five more books before we
take care of the others
i guess i guess uh dumbledore i wanted
to tell you
kind of starts to deal with one of them
in book six i swear i didn't mean to
riddle made me do it little mates all
right
riddle's finished come on ginny let's
get out of here
i guess dumbledore does he he actually
does destroy it in book six
harry yeah there they are
how are you feeling a lot better now
thanks i'm
really disappointed with all that's
happening the mandrake drop
has cancelled this year's exams i was
really looking forward to doing all of
that revision
all exams
anyway did you know that the house cup
is about to be awarded oh how's cup time
dude he's in the great hall
let's see if slytherin winning the uh
quidditch cup
put them on top for the house we managed
to do it two years in a row
well when you're ready harry we'll go in
i mean why wouldn't i be oh here we go
dude if you do not have enough points
to secure the house cup there is still
time explore and excel at
all the challenges throughout hogwarts
and you will be rewarded oh so we can
check the points right here
300 250 200 540
oh my goodness hey albus what's up dude
can i talk to you royalty is a virtue
harry
never forget that i really like this
model of dumbledore
like it's just kind of exactly how i
pictured him in my head reading the
books
uh being in the us and reading the us
versions like
mary grand praise artwork really did
impact how i viewed the characters and
honestly probably this this game as well
but yeah man i don't really know let's
let's take a look here at what we have
because we've got you know what i think
i'm going to create a save here
and then maybe in a future video or
something
we might come back and try to get all of
the uh wizard cards or something
but for now let's go ahead and go on
into the great hall since we just
i mean absolutely dominated even losing
the quidditch club look at that man
540 to 300 dumbledore hasn't even
awarded his last minute points yet
either
or maybe he has actually we come to the
end of another
and so for their many achievements and
outstanding commitments oh yeah we
haven't gotten yet it's a great pleasure
that i present oh house cover he's just
like a gryffindor
it's gonna give all of it let's go ahead
and give it straight to gryffindor
oh my goodness they look so mad wait
that's it really we don't get the
awkward scene with hagrid
like in the movies i love hagrid dude
but man that scene was like wait what
oh everything is here for nearly a
quarter of an hour he spoke into the
wrapped silence
he told them about hearing the
disembodied voice
yep just tell him everything harry how
hermione had finally realized that he
was hearing a basilisk in the pipes
how he and ron following a hint from
hagrid
had followed the spiders into the forest
that aragog had told them where the last
victim of the basilisk
50 years before had died how he had
guessed that moaning myrtle had been the
victim
and that the entrance to the basilisks
the chamber of
secrets might be in her bathroom
but how did you all get out of there
alive well it had a lot to do with you
yeah i just realized friendship lockhart
man
harry you can't forget that lockhart yes
it was like two totally different events
ago lord voldemort as the 16 year old
tom riddle
had enchanted his diary and that diary
had enchanted ginny
and i'm pretty sure this is the point
malfoy who had planted dan riddle's
diary on the happiness dumbledore really
starts to
think this is harry
he truly was the boy who
lived and that's it
that's it man there we go what an
awkward ending
what an awkward ending overall though
like
i still adore this game man i adore this
game
it's by modern standards even by old
standards it's not like a top tier game
you know like if i was reviewing it
it's definitely not a nine i don't even
know if i'd say an eight it's probably
like in that
seven six range because it i do think
it's a quality game
but um yeah i don't know if it's
technology at the time or if they were
just having a rush to meet the deadlines
and whatnot i'm sure they had to rush
because the movie and everything but
yeah it just feels like there was a lot
still left on the table that they could
have done and made better
and and there's just like weird little
things like like just the whole lockhart
bit they're like
oh just cut that out
and i do think there had to be at least
some technical limitations because if
you notice
like ron and harriet's like they
wouldn't let them run together
so whenever we went down to merle's
bathroom ron's harry's like i'll i'll go
first
and so then you go as harry and then all
of a sudden when the cutscene hits runs
right there behind you
but yeah man i really do enjoy the game
and uh
yeah moving on to prisoner of azkaban
next
i don't know we might start playing
something else as well for the let's
plays on the channel
but definitely am going to be moving on
to prisoner of azkaban i think i'm also
going to go with the gamecube version of
that one
that one i do not have nearly as much of
a memory of
as i do a chamber for whatever reason i
don't know
chamber was like the one that i played
the most growing up
i definitely played prisoner of azkaban
but i i don't think i played it nearly
as much as i did
seeing like dust on the edge of my hat
here
nearly as much as i did this one
so yeah and i also want to know let's
take a look here and see if anything
happens
after credits like can i free roam
hogwarts now or does it just take me
back
yeah it takes you right back to the main
menu so
i guess we're going to try to go for
those wizard cards at some point
but yeah man i hope you guys enjoyed
this let's play of harry potter and the
chamber of secrets let me know
what you want to see next other than
harry potter if there are other games
you'd like to see me play
of course we're going to play all the
harry potter games leading up to the
release of hogwarts legacy so you don't
have to worry about that
we're definitely going to play those
quidditch world cup is on the list i had
a poll recently on the channel i don't
know if you guys saw it
but uh on the little community tab i had
a poll of like your favorite
harry potter video game and a lot of
people said quidditch world cup
if a lot of people did so we are
definitely gonna have to have to play
that
and uh have a couple videos up for that
one on the channel
but yeah man i really enjoyed this let's
play series i hope you guys did as well
if you did make sure to give it a thumbs
up before you go
as always guys thank you so much for
watching i'll talk to you again soon